[Applaudissements]
c'est la valise d'isabelle morini-bosc
vous avez mis une enclume de danger
parce que ça qu'est-ce que vous avez mis
leurs plaies deux trois trucs doute que
des propriétés être un petit peu
précises on est à la télé quand même bah
oui parce que ça s'est passé il ya dix
minutes elle a duré de mémoire je le
rappelle le et de 4050 d'attention nous
allons demander à jean michel maire qui
nous a dit avoir été handicapé par un
problème physique pour l'heure à cuire
sa valise
attention jean michel c'est la valise
numéro cinq et il va détrôner à sa belle
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas moi c'est minable à nombre
c'est minable et ça change tout il faut
donc un gage et je demande aux auteurs
de l'émission de bien vouloir me trouver
un accoutrement ridicule pour faire
payer
vous savez je suis le premier accroc
contre les déguisements mais là vous
m'obligez à vous punir c'est la valise
et numéro 5
qu'est ce que tu voudrais voir partir de
la valise numéro 5 monde alexandre le
voyage à madrid
non non rien donc tour à madrid pour ce
voyage disparaître alexandre et bien non
lequel on va lui présenter qu'elle va le
week-end le week-end chez nous ou à les
allumettes ou râteau arthaud qu'on n'en
a éliminé à son nom il n'a pas bien
compris
mais attendez c'est peut-être fin de
noriko macias lycée s'il ne préfère pas
passé le week-end en eric rohmer à lui à
thierry gomar date
tu veux le gagner ou perdre est comme à
siarrouy l'époque j'avais pas compris
non je vais pas le gagner quelque chose
me dit que tu viens à l'instant de
comprendre le principe du jeu
alors